สวัสดีค่ะครูชี้สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะทุกๆคนค่ะขอ
ต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ห้องเรียน competencible ไทยค่ะ
แล้วในวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบ
กันอีกแล้วค่ะในวันนี้
วันศุกร์ค่ะครูปุ๊กวันนี้วันศุกร์ใช่ไหม
คะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
กันยายนค่ะ
ปีอะไรครับพุทธศักราชที่
พุทธศักราชที่
2566 ค่ะ
ปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ในวันศุกร์ที่ 8 เดือนกันยายนเป็นเดือน
ที่ 9 เนาะปีพุทธศักราชหรือพ.ศ
2566 ปีคริสต์ศักราช
2023 ค่ะ
วันนี้เนี่ย
ชั่วโมงภาษาไทยของเราเนี่ยเราอยากให้นัก
เรียนรู้จักกับธรรมชาติเพราะว่าเราบอกว่า
เราเรียนภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาติ
ธรรมชาติเป็นยังไงคะธรรมชาติหรือ
ธรรมชาติก็คืออะไรที่เกิดเองโดยที่คนไม่
ได้สร้าง
นะคะอย่างอันนี้ตึกนี้คนสร้างไม่ใช่
ธรรมชาติ
แม่น้ำคนไม่ได้ทำใช่ไหมเกิดเองใช่ไหมอัน
นี้ธรรมชาติ
[เพลง]
ค่ะ
พระอาทิตย์พระอาทิตย์
พระอาทิตย์เอ่อพระอาทิตย์นี้ก็ทำเองไม่
ได้ค่ะก็ธรรมชาติแต่ถ้าแบบนี้ค่ะ
อันนี้คนทำอันนี้ไม่ใช่ธรรมชาติค่ะ
ก็คือสิ่งที่มันเกิดขึ้นเองเนาะนะก็เรา
เรียกว่าธรรมชาติแล้วเราคุยอะไรเกี่ยวกับ
ธรรมชาติล่ะคะ
ก็บางทีเนี่ยเราอยู่กับธรรมชาติรอบๆตัว
เราเนี่ยแต่บางทีเนี่ยธรรมชาติก็มี
อันตรายค่ะ
ธรรมชาติไม่ดีหรอคะ
ธรรมชาติเนี่ยก็มีทั้งดีและก็มีทั้งไม่ดี
ค่ะ
ครูคิดว่าไม่ดีเนี่ยบางทีเนี่ยมามันอาจจะ
เกิดจากคนที่ทำให้เกิดธรรมชาติเนี่ย
เปลี่ยน
ธรรมชาติก็เลยไม่ดี
ทีนี้ธรรมชาติที่ไม่ดีแล้วเป็นอันตรายกับ
เราเนี่ยเราก็เรียกว่าไพร
เป็นอันตรายเป็นภัยกับเราใช่ไหมเราก็เลย
เรียกสิ่งนั้นว่าภัยธรรมชาติ
วันนี้ก็ครูชิก็จะมาพูดถึงภัยธรรมชาติ
ภัยที่ธรรมชาติเนี่ยทำให้เกิดสิ่งไม่ดี
ที่กับตัวเราใช่ไหมกับกระทบกับตัวเรา
อย่างเช่นอย่างเช่นภัยธรรมชาติที่เกิดจาก
ภัยแล้งค่ะภัยแล้ง
อันนี้แรงจริงๆค่ะ
น่าจะไม่มีน้ำเลยสักหยดนึง
ก็ไม่มีค่ะจนดินเนี่ยมันแตกมันแห้งไม่มี
น้ำเหลือเลยอันนี้ Thailand จริงๆนะโอ้โห
ไม่มีต้นไม้อยู่เลยอ่ะ
ขอโทษขอโทษค่ะ
เวลามันแห้งแล้งมากๆอากาศร้อนมากๆเนี่ย
น้ำมันหายไปหมดในอากาศก็ไม่มีน้ำเพราะ
ฉะนั้น
เวลาร้อนมากๆเนี่ยเวลาลมพัดเนี่ยต้นไม้
มันอาจจะสีกันไปมาไปมาเนาะมันก็อาจจะเกิด
เป็นไฟขึ้นมาใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
เป็นไฟไหม้แต่ไฟไหม้มันก็ไม่อยู่ในป่าไง
ที่มีแต่ต้นไม้เยอะๆถูกไหมโอ้
เวลาไฟไหม้ทีนึงเนี่ยไฟไหม้ป่าเนี่ย
ครูมุกเห็นหูบางทีเนี่ยใช้เวลาหลายวันนะ
ไฟเนี่ยกว่าจะดับลงได้เนี่ยต้องใช้เวลา
เนาะไม่ว่าจะเป็นออสเตรเลียนะประเทศ
ออสเตรเลียประเทศอเมริกาประเทศไทยเองก็มี
ภัยธรรมชาติที่เป็นไฟป่าใช่ไหมนิ้วชี้
เห็นไหมข้างหลังครูชี้เนี่ยมีป่าไม้เยอะ
แต่พอถึงเวลาหน้าแล้งเห็นไหมแรงก็คือแบบ
โอ้น้ำก็ไม่มีแห้งไปหมดเลยนะคะมันก็อาจจะ
เกิดไฟป่าได้แล้วอย่างที่ครูปุ๊กบอกค่ะ
มันดับยากใช่ไหม
เราใช้เวลากับ
ทำไมมันถึงดับยากล่ะคะครูชิคุณปุ๊กก็นี่
มันต้นไม้ทั้งนั้นน่ะ
ต้นไม้มันก็เป็นเชื้อเพลิง
เชื้อเพลิงก็คือเหมือนน้ำมันน้ำมันโดนไฟ
ก็ลุกต้นไม้โดนไฟก็ลุกกระดาษใช่ไหมกระดาษ
เนี่ยโดนไฟก็ลุก
ขึ้นมาเลย
แล้วต้นไม้เนาะพอมันแบบมันแห้งไปมันเผาจน
มันแห้งแล้วอ่ะมันก็เลยกลายเป็นติดไฟ
เพราะติดไฟเนี่ยมันก็ลามจากต้นที่ 1 ไป
ต้นที่ 2 ต้นที่ 3 ต้นที่ 4 โอ้โหแล้วจะ
ต้นหนึ่งเนี่ยมันก็ไม่ใช่ 2 อย่างเดียว
มันก็จะไปต้นอื่นๆอีกนะมันก็เลยกลายเป็น
ไฟที่มันแรงมากนะเอาน้ำมาดับเนี่ยมันก็
ยากละไม่รู้จะไปเอาน้ำที่ไหนนะ
อย่างเวลาไฟไหม้ไฟไฟไหม้ป่าที่ประเทศไทย
อ่ะไม่ทีเป็นภูเขาเลยค่ะภูเขา 1 ลูก 2
ลูก 3 ลูก
ภูเขาเนี่ยเคยไหม้ไปแล้ว T3 ลูกเลยค่ะ
ต้องหาวิธีทำยังไงเวลามีไฟป่าไฟไหม้นะ
แล้วก็จะดับมันได้เนี่ยจะทำยังไง
นะ
ต้องรอต้องรอฝนค่ะ
แต่ถ้าเกิด
ถ้าเกิดฝนมันตกหนักขึ้นนะคะครูปุ๊ก
ฝนตกหนัก
น้ำมันก็น่าจะเต็มแล้วเนาะเพราะว่าดิน
เนี่ยมันดูดน้ำไปแล้ว
มันจะเป็นยังไงคะบลูชิมันก็กัด
มันก็เกิดภัยพิบัติอีกอันนึงค่ะเราเรียก
ว่าน้ำท่วมเป็นไงล่ะ
น้ำเนี่ย
อันนี้เนี่ยท่วมนิดหน่อยไหม
อันนี้เนี่ยท่วมประมาณครึ่งตัวค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ถ้าสูงมากๆเนี่ยก็ต้องย้ายบ้าน
ค่ะไปอยู่บนหลังคาบ้านอันนี้น่าจะท่วมไป 2
เม็ดกว่าแล้วค่ะ
นะ
อยู่ข้างล่างนี้ไม่ได้
เราจะอยู่ยังไงเนี่ยแบบนี้
ก็คิดว่าเวลาที่จะทำอาหารก็คงต้องลงมาค่ะ
แล้วก็ไหว้เข้าไปแล้วก็ไปหาไปงมหาหม้อ
กระทะมาหุงข้าวบนหลังคา
โอ้ยอันนี้ลำบากมากๆเนาะ
น้ำท่วมอันนี้ก็เป็นภัยจริงๆอันตรายนะคะ
นะ
เราว่าน้ำท่วมนี่อันตรายแล้วแต่ถ้าน้ำ
ท่วมเนี่ยมันเอ่อน้ำเนี่ยเยอะฝนตกเยอะ
เนี่ยอยู่บนภูเขาค่ะที่มีต้นไม้ต้นไม้แต่
ต้นไม้เก็บน้ำไม่ไหวแล้วอ่ะครูมุกมันจะ
แบบโอ้โหทะลักลงมาแบบไหลลงมาเราเรียกว่า
น้ำป่าค่ะ
อันนี้ก็เป็นอันตรายเป็นภัยธรรมชาติ
อย่างที่เราบอกนะว่าป่าเมื่อกี้นี้ก็ไฟ
ไหม้ตอนนี้ก็มีน้ำเปล่ามาอีกหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
แล้วทำไมสีมันเป็นแบบนี้คะครูชี้
สีดินไงคะ
เหมือนๆเวลาถ้าเกิดครูปุ๊บไปเที่ยวใช่ไหม
กูปุ๊บไปเที่ยวแล้วกูปุ๊บเนี่ยไปเที่ยวภู
เขา
นะคะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยอาจจะแบบไปเที่ยวน้ำตก
ใช่ไหมไปเล่นน้ำตกอ่านายแองการ่าอย่างนี้
หรอ
แต่ถ้าเกิดกูปุ๊บไปอยู่กับน้ำตกแล้วเนี่ย
ครูปุ๊กเห็นน้ำตกเนี่ยที่ไหลมาเนี่ยมันมี
สีออกสีน้ำตาลแบบเมื่อสักครู่เนี่ยค่ะครู
ปุ๊กต้องเริ่มหนีแล้วค่ะเอ่อหนีไปไหนคะ
หนีทำไมคะหนีให้สูงค่ะอย่าไปอยู่ที่ใกล้ๆ
แม่น้ำหรือเอ่อบริเวณไหน
ก็คือปกติน้ำไหลไปแบบนี้เราต้องวิ่งขึ้น
ภูเขาใช่ไหม
วิ่งภูเขาไม่ใช่ไปกับน้ำน้ำใครทางเดียว
กับน้ำนะนักเรียนเราต้องออกจากน้ำให้สูง
กว่าน้ำค่ะ
เพราะว่าอะไรคะครูชิเพราะว่าเวลามันน้ำ
ป่าที่มันเก็บน้ำไว้เยอะๆมันทะลักลงมาที
เนี่ยทะลักก็คือแบบว่ามันเบรคไม่อยู่แล้ว
ต้นไม้เอาไม่อยู่แล้วน้ำมันเริ่มเยอะขึ้น
เยอะขึ้นเยอะขึ้นบางทีมันทำต้นไม้ล้มแมลง
เลยค่ะนะเอาต้นไม้ล้มด้วยดินมาด้วยอืมก็
คือมาทั้งหมดเลยใช่ไหม
เอออันตรายแล้วของปุ๊ปเออแล้วมาทีนึง
เนี่ยน้ำเยอะมากนะ
แล้วไม่ได้แค่น้ำไงมีดินอย่างที่กูชี้บอก
มีโคลน
นะมีต้นไม้มาด้วยนะ
โอ้โหถ้าหลบไม่ทันหนีไม่ทันเนี่ยไปกับน้ำ
เลยค่ะแล้วก็ไม่ต้องคิดเลยอาจจะแบบฝังกลบ
ไปเลยเพราะว่ามีดินมาด้วยทีนี้แหละนะ
อยู่ใต้ดินเลย
น่ากลัว
3 คนช่วยกันดึงอ่ะยังสู้แรงน้ำไม่ไหวเลย
อันนี้ก็เป็นภัยธรรมชาติที่น่ากลัวนะ
น้ำป่าน้ำป่าแล้วพาดินโคลนเนี่ยถล่มลงมา
ด้วยหรือเปล่าซูชิ
ถล่มมาด้วยค่ะอันนี้ก็อันตรายค่ะเห็นไหม
พอเราบอกว่าแล้งก็เป็นภัยธรรมชาติพอถึง
เวลาหน้าฝนแล้วฝนมากเกินไปน้ำเยอะเกินไป
นี่ค่ะ
นอกจากเอาน้ำลงมาแล้วก็เอาดินมาทับบ้านคน
หมดเลยค่ะเนี่ย
ดินฟรีอันนี้ไม่โอเคนะคะ
โอ้โห
น่าจะไม่ไหวค่ะต้องออกทางหลังคาข้างบนค่ะ
อันนี้ก็เป็นภัยธรรมชาติอย่างหนึ่งเหมือน
กันโหแล้วมาแบบสูงเลยนะ
ร่วมหลังคาเลยอ่ะ
อันนี้ภัยจากคนถล่มใช่ไหมใช่
เราก็จะเจอ
ช่วงที่หน้าฝนในประเทศไทยนะก็มีเหมือนกัน
นะ
เจอเหมือนกัน
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยหน้าฝนนักเรียนถ้าไป
เที่ยวน้ำตกนะน้ำตกที่มีน้ำจากภูเขาไหลลง
มาเนอะอันนี้ต้องระวังมากๆค่ะเพราะว่าน้ำ
ที่เราไม่เห็นเนี่ยว่าฝนตกข้างบนภูเขานะ
ข้างบนภูเขาเนี่ยฝนตกมากแค่ไหนนะแต่เรา
สังเกตน้ำถ้าน้ำยังใสอยู่เล่นน้ำได้
แต่ถ้าน้ำคุณน้ำสีแดงน้ำสีน้ำตาลนะก็คือ
น้ำจากดินและมันเปลี่ยนละเราต้องรีบหนี
ออกจากน้ำนะขึ้นภูเขาขึ้นที่สูงให้นะสูง
ที่สุดให้มากที่สุดนะ
เพราะว่าถ้ามาทิ้งนะกลัว
อันเนี้ยน้ำเปล่าว่าอันตรายแล้วรุนแรง
แล้วมีน้ำอีกอย่างนึงที่มาทีก็น่ากลัวมาก
กว่าอีกค่ะยังมีน้ำอะไรอีกหรอคะคุณชี้น้ำ
ทะเลค่ะแต่มาแบบเป็นคลื่นไม่ใช่คลื่น
ธรรมดาแต่เป็นคลื่นยักษ์
เนี่ยไม่ใช่ยักษ์ที่มีเขี้ยวนะแต่ว่าเป็น
ยักษ์เนี่ยหมายถึงใหญ่มากใช่มั้ย
ใช่ค่ะ
อันนี้เนี่ย
คลื่นอะไรสูงขนาดนี้เลยหรอคะนักเรียนดูดี
ดูป้ายก็ยังเล็กๆรถเนี่ย
หนีไม่ทันเลยหรอคะ
หนีไม่ทันค่ะถูกพัดถูกซัด
อันนี้บ้านก็ไปรถก็ไปค่ะ
น้ำแบบนี้เลยเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
สึนามิขึ้นยักษ์สึนามิ
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะ
ถ้าเราดูนะโอ้โหซัดมาเข้าฝั่งเนี่ยบ้าน
เบิ้ลเนี่ยไปหมดค่ะ
ประเทศไทยก็เคยมีสึนามิ 1 ครั้งนะที่เรา
รู้
ไปโอ้โห
คนเสียชีวิตไปเยอะเหมือนกันมีไม่ทันเพราะ
ว่าประเทศไทยไม่ค่อยมีภัยธรรมชาติที่เป็น
คลื่นยักษ์
ไม่เคยเจอสึนามิไงแล้วเราก็เลยไม่มี
สัญญาณเตือนที่บริเวณทะเลหรือชายหาดปรากฏ
ว่าพอขึ้นน้ำทะเลเนี่ยมันลดไป
มันแห้งไปจากอันนี้อันนี้เป็นเป็นชายหาด
ใช่ไหมแล้วก็มีน้ำทะเลอยู่เนี่ยนะน้ำทะเล
มันลดแบบเร็วมากคุณปุ๊กนะคะคนไทยไม่ได้
หนีขึ้นข้างบนค่ะเพราะไม่รู้จักสึนามิมี
คนก็เดินไปแล้วก็ไปถ่ายรูปทำไมน้ำทะเลหาย
จับปลาได้ใช่ไหมจากน้ำทะเลอ่ะสมมุติอัน
นี้เป็นน้ำทะเล
ซัดเข้ามาหาฝั่งเนาะแล้วก็อันนี้ข้างล่าง
เป็นทรายน้ำทะเลเนี่ยอยู่ๆมันจะหายไปเลย
หรอคะครูชี้มันลดเร็วค่ะ
แล้วก็ค่อยๆหายไปนะเหลือน้ำนิดหน่อยใน
เวลาไม่ถึงชั่วโมงใช่มั้ย
ใช่ค่ะ
กุ๊กๆแล้วคนไทยไม่เคยเจอสึนามิไงเราก็รู้
สึกอ้าวบางคนแบบอ้าวน้ำทะเลหายไปไหนเนี่ย
แล้วมันก็ลดไปเร็วมากก็แบบแปลกไงก็ไปถ่าย
รูปพอสักพักน้ำมาค่ะ
เป็นคลื่นมาแบบอย่างใหญ่เลยหนีไม่ทันแล้ว
วิ่งทันไหมคุชิวิ่งก็ไม่ทันแล้วค่ะนะคะ
เพราะทุกคนคิดอุ๊ยคลื่นใหญ่ไม่เคยเห็นพอ
ใกล้ฝั่งมันยิ่งใหญ่มากขึ้นนะดูไกลๆเนี่ย
มันขึ้นใหญ่เท่านี้พอมาถึงข้างโอ้โหใคร
ใกล้ฝั่งนี้ขึ้นเริ่มสูงมากขึ้นสูงมาก
ขึ้น
คนที่หาดแล้วก็เข้าไปตามบ้านตามอะไรวิ่ง
หนีกันไม่ไหวต้องวิ่งขึ้นขึ้นตึก
ขึ้นที่สูง
ก็บางทีเนี่ยไม่ใช่โรงแรมที่เรานอนเราก็
ต้องไปค่ะ
กลัวตายใช่ไหมเพราะว่าคลื่นมันสูงมากๆ
แล้วมันซัดมาทีนึงเนี่ยโอ้โหเอาเรือมา
ด้วยครูปุ๊กเห็นมีเรือนะโอ้โหขึ้นมาอยู่
ข้างบนฝั่งเลยค่ะ
ขึ้นไป
ก็คิดดูเร็วว่าคลื่นมันใหญ่ขนาดไหน
ช่วงนั้นก็เลยมีคนที่ตายไปหลายคนเพราะว่า
ภัยธรรมชาติที่เราเรียกว่าสึนามิเนี่ย
เกิดมาเนี่ย
ไม่เคยได้ยินคำว่าสึนามิจนประเทศไทยมี
นั่นแหละครูก็เพิ่งได้เคยได้ยินว่าอ๋ออัน
นี้เขาเรียกว่าคลื่นสึนามิขึ้นยักษ์นะ
คลื่นยักษ์สึนามิแล้วมาช่วงใกล้คริสต์มาส
ด้วยไงคนหรือนักท่องเที่ยวเยอะก็เลยมีคน
เสียชีวิตเยอะเลยไงโอ้โหน่าสงสารมากนะครู
ชี้ก็กำลังจะไปเที่ยวภาคใต้เหมือนกัน
นะคะพอดีเกิดสึนามิก่อนนะ
พอได้ยินข่าวขับรถกลับบ้านค่ะ
เกิด 26 ไหม
คะ
แต่งงาน 25 ไง
แล้ววันที่
26 เช้าอ่ะมันเกิดตอนเช้าเลยประมาณ 9:00
นมั้ย 7 เมนูประมาณเนี้ยนะที่เกิดสึนามิ
ใช่เพราะจัดคริสต์มาสที่กรุงเทพฯก่อนแล้ว
ก็ค่อยเดินทางคือไม่ไปวันคริสต์มาสเพราะ
ว่าเราจัดคริสต์มาสที่กรุงเทพฯก่อนแล้ว
คิดว่าจะเดินทางไปวันที่ 26 เราก็คิดว่า
ก่อนอ้าวไม่ใช่หลัง 1 วัน
ก็คือน้องแต่งงาน
น้องที่ทำงานนี่แหละแต่งงานต้องไปงานน้อง
ไงก็เลยหลายคนเนี่ยมีแพลนว่าจะไปนะภาคใต้
ก็ยังไม่ได้ไปไงเพราะว่าต้องไปปาร์ตี้งาน
แต่งงานก่อน
ก็เลยโชคดีว่าไม่ได้ไปตอนนั้นไม่อย่าง
นั้นก็คงจะมีอยู่ในข่าวมา
อันนี้ก็เป็นภัยธรรมชาติที่น่ากลัวนะ
เพราะว่าเราไม่เคยเจอแล้วพอเจอทีมก็โอ้โห
ตอนนี้เรารู้จักแล้วแล้วก็รู้ว่าเวลามี
อันตรายจาก
สึนามิเนี่ยเราต้องหนียังไง
ตอนพอมีสึนามในหนังสือเรียนมีสึนามิแล้ว
อาหารแล้วก็มีสึนามิที่เราแบบโอ้โหเรา
ต้องไปหาข้อมูลเนอะไปหาอินเทอร์เน็ตไปหา
จากอะไรตอนนี้มันข้อมูลเราหาง่ายไงไม่
ต้องเป็นหนังสืออย่างเดียวนะฮะก็เลยทำให้
แบบคนรู้จักมากขึ้นที่ประเทศไทยเคยมีแล้ว
1 ครั้งที่ตั้งแต่เราเกิดมาจนโตเนี่ยมี 1
ครั้ง
ทีนี้เราเจอภัยแล้งก็คือไม่มีน้ำไม่มีไหล
แห้งแล้งเราเจอภัยที่เกิดจากน้ำนะคะภัย
ที่เกิดจากน้ำไม่ว่าจะเป็นน้ำน้ำท่วมน้ำ
ป่าน้ำป่าก็มีคนถล่มมาอีกใช่ไหม
เราก็ตอนนี้เรามาดูธรรมชาติที่อยู่บนท้อง
ฟ้าบ้าง
มีอะไรบ้างคะ
อย่างท้องฟ้าเนี่ยปุ๊กเห็นไหมเดี๋ยวนี้
ทำไมแบบเราจะเจอฟ้าแลบ
อ๋อเหมือนแสงแฟลชใช่ไหมแล้วแบบ
เราเยอะขึ้น
นะ
แล้วจากฟ้าแลบเนี่ยนะ
ฟ้าแลบเสร็จแล้วมันจะมีเสียงค่ะ
มันจะเป็นฟ้าร้องนะมันจะมีเสียงแบบฮื่อ
อ๋อไม่ได้รับ
ไม่อันนี้อันนี้เราอ่ะต้องลองค่ะเพราะว่า
กลัว
นะไม่ได้ร้องฮือใช่ไหมใช่แต่มันร้องแบบ
มันมันมีเสียงอ่ะซึ่งมันแบบโอ้โหถ้าใคร
ที่อยู่คอนโดมิเนียมสูงๆเนาะแล้วเป็นแบบ
กระจกอ่ะ
เป็นไม่ใช่ปูนซีเมนต์นะเป็นกระจกอ่ะมัน
สั่นเลยนะซูชิ
ฟ้าร้องใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเวลาฟ้าร้องเนี่ยมัน
จะมีเสียงดังไง
โอ้โห
กระจกเนี่ยมันจะ
สั้นๆนะคะ
ใช่แต่อันนี้มันสั่นแบบเหมือนแบบมันเป็น
แรงแค่ฟ้านะเสียงฟ้าร้องนี่มันสะเทือน
ขนาดนี้
จากฟ้าแลบแล้วฟ้าร้อง
มีอะไรอีกไหม
ฟ้าแลบฟ้าร้องนี่ก็คืออันนี้ค่ะฟ้าผ่าค่ะ
อันนี้ไฟไฟลุกเลยค่ะอันนี้น่ากลัวจริง
ด้วยครูชิแล้วตึกนี้เขาจะเป็นอะไรไหมคะ
เขามีสายล่อฟ้าค่ะมีมีสายสำหรับเล่าให้
ฟ้าลงมาที่นี่นะคะตึกก็เลยไม่แบบไม่
อันตรายมากเพราะว่าให้มันวิ่งมาที่เส้น
เดียวแต่ฟ้าผ่าเดี๋ยวนี้มันอุ๊ยมันแรงไง
มันแรงกว่าสมัยที่คุณชี้ยังเด็กๆ
น่ากลัว
หนูก็คิดว่ามันมีมลพิษในอากาศเยอะค่ะ
นะไม่ว่าจะแบบ
คาร์บอนมอนอกไซด์นะฝุ่นฝุ่นที่เราแบบ
สกปรกมีฝุ่น
ลอยนะเพราะว่าเราสร้างคอนโดมิเนียมทำ
อพาร์ทเม้นท์ทำอะไรเยอะแยะเนี่ยมันก็จะมี
ฝุ่นค่ะฝุ่นจากดินทรายปูนอย่างนี้ค่ะปูน
ซีเมนต์อย่างนี้มันก็กลายเป็นฝุ่นในอากาศ
นะ
มันน่ากลัวมากขึ้นเรื่อยๆครูปุ๊กใช่เพราะ
ว่าอย่างเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยฟ้าผ่าที่กุชชี่
บอกเนี่ยมันจะผ่าแบบไม่ได้รุนแรงขนาดนี้
อ่ะขนาดกุชชี่โอ้โหจีบตึกก็โดนหมดเลยอ่ะ
เพราะว่ามันจะผ่าลงที่ที่สูงที่สุดใช่ไหม
นะแต่ตอนนี้ทุกตึกเนี่ยที่ทำสูงๆเนี่ยเขา
ก็จะมีสายสำหรับล่อฟ้าก็คือเวลาฟ้าผ่ามา
มันจะเปรี้ยงเสร็จแล้วมันจะมาที่ยอดตึก
อันเนี้ยมันจะมีสายล่อฟ้าที่มันจะไม่ลง
ที่ตัวตึกมันจะลงไปที่สายนะแล้วลงดินนะฮะ
แต่ว่าคิดว่าตึกก็ต้องสะเทือนแล้วแหละ
ซูชิมันต้องสั่นสะเทือนค่ะ
ฟ้าผ่าเนี่ยเคยมีคนที่โดนฟ้าผ่าแล้วก็ตาย
หลายคนภัยต่อมาค่ะครูปุ๊ก
อะไรคะเนี่ยซูชิ
ภูเขาไฟระเบิดค่ะ
อันนี้ระเบิดเลยแต่โชคดีนะประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ไม่มีภูเขาไฟแล้วใช่ไหมโดยชี้ไม่มีแล้ว
ค่ะไม่มีภูเขาไฟแล้ว
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราอาจจะไม่เจอภูเขาไฟ
ระเบิด
เราก็เลยไม่เจออันตรายตรงนั้นเนาะแต่เวลา
ดูหนังเนอะ
โอ้โหเป็นไฟเลยอ่ะซูชิน่ากลัวมาก
แล้วก็นะเห็นคนที่เขาหนีอ่ะหนีออกมาเนี่ย
โอ้โหบางคนหนีไม่ทันเนี่ยอันตรายมากเนอะ
เฮ้ยมันน่าจะร้อนมากๆค่ะนะกลัวมากค่ะ
นะคะ
อันนี้ภัยจากฟ้าใช่มั้ยภัยจากฟ้าไปแล้ว
เนี่ยเราก็จะมีภัยธรรมชาติที่เกิดจากลม
ค่ะลม
ลมไม่ดีหรอคะครูชิ
ลมนิดหน่อยดีค่ะเย็นสบายค่ะแต่ถ้าลมมากๆ
จนขนาดนี้เนี่ยบ้านก็ไปค่ะหลังคาบ้าน
หลังคาเนี่ย
หลังคาหายโอ้โหคุชิจะอยู่ยังไงนะคะครู
ปุ๊กหลังคาบ้านหายไปแล้วอ่ะ
อันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กว่านะประเทศไทยยังโชค
ดีไม่ค่อยมีนะเราจะมีแค่นิดหน่อยไม่เยอะ
แบบเล็กๆค่ะที่ทะเลนะมากๆจะเกิดที่ทะเลนะ
แต่ว่าถ้าเป็นอเมริกาอะไรแบบนี้เขาจะเจอ
นะ
พายุทอร์นาโด
พายุไซโคลนพายุเฮอริเคน
ไม่รู้เจออะไรบ้าง
น้องไอ้ฝุ่น
ไต้ฝุ่นเนี่ยจะเป็นเอเซียเนาะไปฝุ่นนะก็
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเจอน้อยมากนะเคยเจอ 1
ครั้งนะตั้งแต่เกิดมาก็เพิ่งเจอ 1 ครั้ง
ทั้งภาคใต้ค่ะ
อืม
แต่ว่า
พายุเนี่ยกว่าจะมาถึงประเทศไทยมันลดจาก
ที่แข็งแรงอ่ะมันหมดแรงมาถึงประเทศไทยก็
เป็นดีเปรสชั่นแล้วก็สบายๆแล้ว
อะไรก็กลายเป็นพายุฝนนะมีฝนตกเยอะอะไรแบบ
นี้นะแต่นับว่าธรรมชาติเนี่ยกับประเทศไทย
เนี่ยยังโชคดีนะ
ว่าเราไม่มีแบบอะไรที่มันแรงๆมากเกิน
ประเทศที่เรามีฝนมีฟ้าแล้วใช่ไหมมีลมแล้ว
ใช่ไหมอันนี้แผ่นดินค่ะ
เอ้าแผ่นดินก็มีอีกหรอคะดูซิ
ใช่ค่ะแผ่นดินไหวค่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
กี่ริกเตอร์ค่ะจะได้แบบนี้
โอ้โห
มีแผ่นดิน
แปะริกเตอร์การริกเตอร์อะไรแบบนี้นะมันก็
จะมีการสั่นไหวของแผ่นดินแล้วมันก็จะแยก
กันค่ะ
นะทำให้แผ่นดินน่ะมันแยกออกจากกันเนาะ
แผ่นดินไหวก็น่ากลัว
ปัญหาแผ่นดินไหวค่ะ
บ้านทรุดลงมาเลย
น่าสงสารมากที่สุดก็คือถ้าเกิดบ้านไม่
แข็งแรงครูปุ๊กดูเด่นเนี่ยเห็นไหมพอแผ่น
ดินไหวทิ้งร้าวเลยเห็นไหมคะ
โอ้โหและร้าวอันนี้
โชคดีนะยังไม่พังลงมาดูดิใกล้แล้วอ่ะ
แต่ข้างๆเนี่ยไปหมดแล้วอ่ะถล่มลงไปหมด
แล้วอ่ะ
ใช่
อันนี้คนต้องรีบออกมาหนีให้ไกลๆเลยค่ะ
นะ
เมื่อไหร่มันแบบสั่นอีกนิดเดียวเพราะว่า
มันมี After  Shock เนาะนะหลายๆครั้งไม่
ใช่แผ่นดินไหวครั้งเดียวค่ะมันจะเกิด
After  Shock ครั้งที่ 1 ครั้งที่ 2
แล้วแต่เนาะนะเออมันอาจจะน้อยลงแต่ว่ามัน
ก็มีความรุนแรงอยู่นะต้องรีบออกจากบ้าน
เลยค่ะถ้าร้าวขนาดนี้แล้วก็มันจะถล่มปึ้ง
ลงมาเลยนะ
บ้านอยู่ชั้นบนสุดมันจะมาอยู่ชั้นล่างค่ะ
อันนี้ก็ประเทศไทยไม่ค่อยมีเนาะเรามีแค่
มันแค่ปลายๆแผ่นดินไหวอ่ะมันไม่ได้แบบ
เต็มที่กับเราคือเราไม่ค่อยอยู่ตรงจุด
ศูนย์กลางไง
จุดศูนย์กลางแล้วก็มันออกไปใช่ไหม
แต่ว่ามันไม่ได้เกิดที่ประเทศไทยมากๆแล้ว
เราอ่ะมันจะเกิดที่ทะเลมั่งอินโดนีเซีย
หรือฟิลิปปินส์หรืออะไรแบบนี้เนาะหรือว่า
พม่าแล้วก็ไทยเนี่ยมันสั่นสะเทือนปลายๆ
ค่ะแล้วก็เลยแบบริกเตอร์มันก็เลยไม่เยอะ
ก็
นี่ก็คือภัยธรรมชาติค่ะ
ให้ค่ะใครธรรมชาติจริงๆก็ยังมีภัย
ธรรมชาติอีกนะคะครูปุ๊กใช่ไหมนะคะซึ่ง
ประเทศไทยอาจจะไม่มี
นะคะเป็นภัยแบบพายุทรายมาแบบเป็นพายุเลย
แล้วก็เอาทรายมา
นะคะน่าจะเป็น
ทะเลทรายส่วนที่มันเป็นทรายที่แบบโอ้โห
ร้อนอากาศร้อนมากๆตอนกลางคืนก็หนาวมากๆนะ
เพราะว่าพื้นดินเนี่ยจะเป็นทรายนะก็ตอน
กลางคืนก็จะเกิดเถอะแบบพายุส่ายถล่ม
หรือไม่ก็ประเทศที่มีหิมะใช่ไหมประเทศไทย
ไม่มีประเทศที่มีหิมะก็อาจจะมีภัย
ธรรมชาติที่เป็นหิมะถล่มใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่าหิมะที่มันตกมาหนาขึ้นสูงขึ้นสูง
ขึ้นน้ำมันก็จะกลายเป็นแบบเหมือนภูเขา
หิมะ
แล้วก็จากภูเขาที่มันเป็นหิมะมันอาจจะ
สไลด์ตัวลงมาค่ะเราบอกว่าหิมะเนี่ยมันพัด
ลมลงมาค่ะนะแล้วก็ถ้ามีใครไปเล่นสกีอยู่
ตรงนั้นเนี่ยโอ้โหมีโอกาสถูกฝังอยู่ใน
นั้นในโอ้โหนี่เลยค่ะตามรูปเลยค่ะ
นะถ้าใครเล่นสกีอยู่ตรงนี้เนี่ยอันตราย
มากเลยค่ะ
ใช่
นะฮะก็ต้องช่วยกันขุดนะคะอันนี้เรามาสรุป
กันอีกครั้งค่ะว่าภัยธรรมชาติของเราเนี่ย
มีอะไรบ้างนะคะให้นักเรียนรู้จักนะก็มี
ภัยจากน้ำใช่ไหม
สึนามิขึ้นยักษ์
ขึ้นยักษ์นะลื่น
นะแต่มันขึ้นใหญ่ใช่มั้ยขึ้นยักษ์สึนามิ
อ่าแล้วก็รูปที่ 2 เนี่ยก็คือ Thailand
เพราะว่าไม่มีน้ำนะแห้งแล้งไปหมดเลย
ภัยแล้งก็ทำให้คนตายได้ไม่มีอะไรกิน
ร้อนจนตายอันที่ 3 นี้ก็คือคนถล่มดินถล่ม
นะจากภูเขา
ใช่ดินโคลนถล่มก็คือน้ำมันเยอะข้างบนแล้ว
มันก็เลยเอาดินลงมาสไลด์ลงมาเหมือนกัน
แล้วก็แผ่นดินไหวค่ะใช่ค่ะ
แผ่นดินไหวนะประเทศไทยนิดหน่อยค่ะ
แล้วก็พายุทอร์นาโดในนี้โชคดีที่ประเทศ
ไทยไม่มี
[เพลง]
ภูเขาไฟระเบิด
อันนี้ประเทศไทยก็ไม่มี
ประเทศไทยมีอันนี้ค่ะ
ทุกปีค่ะน้ำท่วม
น้ำท่วมทุกปี
ต่อมา
พายุทรายไม่มีค่ะประเทศไทยไม่มี
ภาษามันจะเติบโตอยู่ในหัวเราเหมือนๆต้น
ไม้ค่ะ
เหมือนต้นไม้นะคะวันนี้เราก็หมดเวลาแล้ว
สำหรับคลาส complate
แล้วก็มาพบกันใหม่นะคะนะในคลิปต่อไปค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณค่ะ